>>> YOU LOVE HER.
YOU CHERISH HER.
BUT LET'S FACE IT.
SHE'S A LOT.
>> I CAN'T EAT ANYTHING HERE.
>> BECAUSE SHE'S PROVOCATIVE.
BECAUSE SHE'S MAGNETIC.
BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING.
>> THERE'S NOBODY GOOD HERE.
>> YOU GIVE HER THE SUN, THE
MOON, AND THE STARS.
BUT FOR NOW, GIVE HER SOMETHING
TO DISTRACT HER.
CARTIER PRESENTS THE
DIAMOND-ENCRUSTED FIDGET
SPINNER.
14 KARAT GOLD.
A LUXURIOUS TOY GUARANTEED TO
KEEP HER OCCUPIED.
>> SO FAST.
>> YOU DO YOU AND HER DO THAT.
>> I'M BALANCING IT.
EMBEDDED WITH PRINCESS CUT
DIAMONDS DESIGNED TO CALM HER
BECAUSE SHE, QUOTE, HAS ANXIETY.
SHE'S VIVACIOUS, SHE'S FEISTY.
SHE'S ALWAYS KIND OF FEUDING
WITH A FRIEND.
SHE TOLD YOU SHE'S THINKING OF
OPENING A RESTAURANT AND YOU'RE
LIKE, I GUESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GIVE HER SOMETHING TO FOCUS ON
BECAUSE, LET'S FACE IT, SHE'S
BEEN READING "THE GOLDFINCH" FOR
TWO YEARS.
SHE LITTERS.
SHE HAS TO TAKE CABS BECAUSE HER
UBER RATING IS SO LOW.
WHEN SHE'S AROUND GAY MEN IT'S
EXACTLY HOW YOU THINK IT WOULD
BE.
AND YOU KNOW SHE'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PERSON WITH HER
FAMILY.
>> HI, DADDY!
>> INTRIGUING.
ADDICTIVE.
A WAY TO PASS THE TIME.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE FIDGET
SPINNER.
>> HEY, CAN WE GO?
I'M REALLY SICK.
>> OKAY.
>> CARTIER FIDGET SPINNER.
BECAUSE, GOD, THE SEX IS GOOD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]